otro globo chino ha sido avistado esta
vez en cielos latinoamericanos según el
pentágono
estamos viendo informes de un globo en
tránsito por América Latina estamos
evaluando si es otro globo de vigilancia
chino el periódico local costarricense
la nación ha informado de avistamientos
de un globo pero ninguna organización
meteorológica nacional sea
responsabilizado de la nave el anuncio
se produce un día después de que un
globo similar fuera avistado en los
cielos de Estados Unidos por este primer
globo china lamentó lo sucedido y culpó
a los vientos por empujar al espacio
aéreo de Estados Unidos lo que Beijing
considera que es solo una aeronave civil
china es un país responsable que siempre
ha acatado estrictamente las leyes
internacionales y no tiene intención de
violar el territorio y el espacio aéreo
de ningún país soberano las tensiones
entre Estados Unidos y China ya son
elevadas y los avistamientos han
deteriorado aún más la relación el
secretario de estado Anthony blinken ha
decidido Cancelar su viaje a Beijing
previsto para este domingo la presencia
de este globo de vigilancia en el
espacio aéreo estadounidense es una
Clara violación de la Estados Unidos y
del derecho internacional es un acto
irresponsable y la decisión de la
República popular china llevar a cabo
esta acción en vísperas de mi visita
prevista van detrimento de las
conversaciones que estábamos dispuestos
a mantener el gobierno chino ha negado
que hubiera alguna visita planeada y
declaró un accidente de fuerza mayor lo
ocurrido con el globo
la administración del presidente
estadounidense Joe biden ha decidido no
destruir el primer globo que aún se
encuentra sobre el territorio
continental del país norteamericano
estos globos utilizan helio por eso
cuando la gente habla de derribarlo no
es el handerbook no se puede disparar y
luego arder en llamas Este es un gas
inerte si le haces agujeros se escapará
muy lentamente
según las autoridades estadounidenses
este globo no representa un riesgo
militar para las personas que viven en
suelo estadounidense